Sal Pao guus airport
Brazil and Jorge Chavez in Lima
Peru two of South America's busiest and
two important choke points in the global
fight against illicit
[Music]
drugs Peru is one of the world's top
cocaine
producers Brazil is a major for cocaine
heading to
Europe and annual seizures at either
airport can reach a ton or
more the loads are
large the busts often measured in
bricks these are some that tip the
scales
247365 the flights never stop nor does
the work of the security Personnel at
these Latin American
airports Sal Pao guus airport
Brazil the busiest airport in South
America handles
116,000 passengers a
day and cocaine seizures here also lead
the continent regularly surpassing one
ton annually the Brazilian federal
police spearhead the anti-narcotics
efforts a flight to Johannesburg South
Africa prepares for departure for
officers it's a high trafficking route
the Africa has become a major trans
shipment point in 2018 nearly half of
the carriers arrested for drugs here had
African
destinations and almost 25% of those
were headed to
Johannesburg in the check-in area police
flag Two Men and take them in for
further
[Music]
inspection they were stopped at check
we asked them several questions about
their situation residence work
family we do this until they contradict
themselves the passengers appear
shaken and the police will inspect the
pair
separately
foree
speech
foreign
for
spee
it is a situation that immediately races
flag a traveler says he does not have a
key to his bag it was
[Music]
suspicious the agents moved to bust the
lock and find out if the man is
lying
Jorge Chavez International Airport Lima
Peru number three in South America for
passenger traffic for anti-narcotics
police here international flights are a
primary focus as they work to hinder the
global cocaine
trade Peru is the world's number two
cocaine producer behind
Colombia a flight to Madrid is about to
board and agents receive an
alert one of its check bags appears to
contain something
illegal a suitcase was flaged by the
security system we went to get the bag
and another group went to find the
passenger and take him to the inspection
area
boarding will begin in only a few
minutes so agents act quickly they don't
want the man to miss his flight if the
bag is
[Music]
clean
yeah
[Music]
pass
flag we noticed in our opinion that the
passenger was too
nervous
something wasn't quite right about
him we tried to convince him to be
honest with us since testing his luggage
for cocaine was UN
avoidable
it doesn't take long to uncover the
packages the man said he was
carrying
Sal Pao guus
Brazil anti-narcotics police flagged two
passengers traveling to South
Africa and they don't appear to handle
the news very very
well the first passenger bag rectangular
brick-like
shapes the international smuggling
standard for
cocaine now the officers move to the
second man's
bag and immediately scan his
luggage the orange color shows organic
matter arranged in all to familiar
sizes his backs were X-ray and a large
amount of organic material was detected
this could indicate
drugs
the passenger appears resigned to his
fate
d
both men will now be taken to Police
Headquarters where the suspicious bricks
will be
analyzed to begin a criminal proceeding
we need scientific proof an expert has
to test the substance to confirm that
the substance is
drugs
the passenger in blue now seems to relax
while the second man remains
silent this thing there are different
kinds of reactions every person is
different so the reactions to specific
situations can also be quite
different the first step in the criminal
process extracting the suspicious
load the officer starts with the
passenger in
Blue 11
bricks and then moves to the second
man's
back his total 22 bricks double the
first man's
tally it's now time to confirm if the
contents are
cocaine
Sal Pao guus
Brazil Federal Police Stopped two
passengers departing for South
Africa and both look to be carrying
large quantities of
[Music]
cocaine the man in blue is inspected
first
the first brick contains cocaine
base an intermediary product in the
process of turning coca leaves into
cocaine
powder but the entire load must be
tested and agents quickly discover
bricks of fully refined cocaine powder
as
well
we see various forms of cocaine it's the
most common drug here at the airport and
accounts for about 80% of what we
see we see the fine refined powder and
that's high
quality we also see less processed
versions but they can also result in
high
Purity the first passenger was
transporting nearly 4 kg of cocaine base
and almost 7 kilos of cocaine
powder his mood seems to
darken but not to the apparent depths of
the other
man his load is confirmed
[Music]
cocaine both men are officially under
arrest and will remain in the airport
jail until fully
processed
despite the officer's encouragement both
men appear unable or unwilling to
[Music]
cooperate
both passengers wave their right to a
phone call they will wait until their
cases are heard before notifying their
families at the airport they will
provide an official statement and will
then be transferred to a federal prison
to await their
[Music]
sentencing for attempting to transport
roughly 11 and 23 kg of cocaine
respectively they could each face 5 to
15 years in
[Music]
prison corge Chavez airport Lima
Peru a passenger preparing to board a
flight to Madrid was stopped by
police yeah
[Music]
came at first the man claims he's only
carrying clothes in his back back but
then he mentions something
else
the criminal proceedings are now turned
over to a
prosecutor agents will extract the drugs
and establish the size of the
load
[Music]
for
it's a large seizure but evidence
suggests that part of the load has gone
missing there were 12 packages marked
from 12 to 23 it was very suspicious
there were supposed to be 23 packages
but only 12 were
there agents searched for another check
bag in the suspect's
name while at headquarters officers
proceed to weigh the cocaine in the
first
bag if the police's suspicions bear out
this already large load could double in
size Jorge Chavez Lima Peru
anti-narcotics police detained a
passenger attempting to smuggle cocaine
to
Madrid and they believe a second check
bag could contain a similar size
load
it will be sent to
headquarters if the second suitcase
contains cocaine the man's situation
could go from bad to
[Music]
worse the missing
numbers the packages most likely contain
cocaine but the agents must still
confirm
it
finally the second load is
weighed
the man faces serious problems the size
of the seizure could change his charge
from basic to aggravated
trafficking he makes his
call
[Music]
the man is transferred to a police
station there he can meet with his
attorney a judge will then determine if
he's guilty of aggravating
trafficking for transporting 15 kilos of
cocaine he could face up to 25 years in
[Music]
prison Sal Pao guus
Brazil it's 2: in the afternoon soon two
flights will depart from Madrid Spain
anti-narcotics agents are on
alert officers received intelligence
that a woman smuggling cocaine would be
on one of the flights it's up to the
agents to find her before
takeoff the case may be more complicated
than they originally
thought now they have two suspects to
track
down
she denied any wrongdoing but despite
what they say we have to open the
suitcases and check
inside with the plane preparing for
takeoff the bags are brought directly to
the
gate now agents must determine if these
passengers are actually drug
carriers
porge Chavez International Airport Lima
Peru behind the scenes here A
specialized police unit inspects the
checked
luggage every year they examine over
30,000 bags for cocaine and other types
of
contraband
a bag checked on a flight to Amsterdam
was flagged for inspection and the owner
must be
located we went to the airline to
request the passengers information this
person was accompanied by her partner we
were able to get a photograph to help us
locate the
person agent must work quickly the
flight has already begun boarding and
they'll need to find the suspect amongst
its 400
passengers I knew this person was
traveling with somebody but I wanted to
ask to see if she would lie to me or not
yes I am traveling alone she told me I
knew that was a
lie
the woman maintains that she is
traveling alone but officials know she
is lying then the agents observe a man
walking nearby and his presence seems to
affect the female passenger
at that moment the lady changed her
expression her eyes got bigger her face
completely changed and I suspected that
this man could be the one we were
looking
for
the couple are taken for inspection the
woman still claims she isn't traveling
with her
ex-husband that taking the same flight
on the same day is a mere
coincidence the police know the woman
has lied once but is she lying
again
[Music]
the alleged ex-husband is
next upon unwrapping the bag another red
flag the passengers seem to be carrying
the same model
suitcase
it's an unbelievable story a man and his
ex traveling separately on the same
flight with identical bags except his
doesn't carry
cocaine
Sal Paulo
Brazil police detain two women flying to
Madrid
Spain the officers have intelligence
that at least one passenger could be
carrying cocaine it's now up to the
agents to confirm confirm the
[Music]
tip cornered one of the women confesses
and the police detain them
both the investigation will continue at
the airport police station then
something
unexpected another suspicious bag from
the same flight but it doesn't belong to
either detainee there may be another
possible carrier on
board
the passenger denies carrying anything
illegal but the x-rays tell a different
story Le
[Music]
sou Paulo
Brazil
two passengers departing from Madrid
Spain were detained on the skybridge and
police quickly uncovered
Contraband then another suspicious bag
and a third passenger were
flagged now agents work to determine if
this bag also hides
drugs
three drug smuggling arrests on the same
flight to Spain and all three appear to
use the same smuggling
method it could all be a
coincidence or or the carriers could all
have been sent by the same
organization a forensics expert will
first extract the drugs from the
bags they begin with the only bag yet to
be
tested it belongs to the female
passenger who did
confess she's also
[Music]
carrying
okay
now the officers work on the other
woman's bag there's no definitive proof
the carriers are part of the same
organization but the evidence points in
that
direction the second suitcase also tests
positive the contents of the third
passenger's bag are analyzed and the
test reveals the same
result finally the work is over the
total amount of cocaine seized nearly 11
kg G the entire load is worth some
$10,000 in Brazil in Spain it has a
value of more than
300,000 all three passengers are under
arrest before they head to the airport
jail one of the women asks for her phone
[Music]
call
M at any age family is what's important
but the fact that they're so young means
it's even more important they're going
to be alone for a while and the family
will need to provide for them today the
detainees will spend the night at the
airport jail tomorrow they will be
transferred to a federal prison if found
guilty of cocaine trafficking they could
face a sentence of 5 to 15
[Music]
years with over 3,000 check bags to
inspect per hour at Sal Pao security
relies heavily on drug sniffing dogs to
get the job
done a dog alerts to a bag heading for
Ethiopia and the police bring its owner
in for an
inspection the woman appears
calm but says she's not feeling
well
when people show any signs of health
problems we call the
medics
the airport Medics are quick to read her
signs was
that it appears the woman is pregnant
for police this information must not
color their
investigation if anything elicit is
found in her bags she will still be
sentenced Jorge Chavez Lima Peru police
arrested a woman carrying cocaine to
[Music]
Amsterdam now they will determine if her
ex-husband is also
involved
as expected positive for
cocaine now the agents work to extract
the
load
it's clear that these two people were
recruited by the same organization since
their luggage matched and the weight of
their drug loads was
similar so far the ex couple have
remained silent during
proceedings not even looking at each
other now they're ready to
talk
[Music]
if found guilty of transporting
approximately 2 kilos of cocaine each
the passengers could both face a
sentence of up to 15 years in
prison
[Music]
Sal Paulo
Brazil drug sniffing dogs alerted to a
check bag destined for Addis Ababa
Ethiopia and police moved to inspect the
bag and the bag's pregnant
owner the woman says she does not know
the bag's combination so police have the
okay to bust it
open
on the inside little more than a
backpack containing a large quantity of
suspicious
packages
the test is positive cocaine the woman
is now under
arrest the total seizure 13 bricks
weighing almost 14 kg
and stamped on the product something the
agents have seen
before over a 2-year span authorities
seized 44 shipments of cocaine with
similar animal stamps
totaling more than 800
kg the officers believe that much of the
stamped cocaine could come from the same
Trafficking
Organization the animals could be a code
to Mark the origin of the product or or
perhaps its
destination this is an interesting case
that shows once again how traffickers
take advantage of the poor of people's
Financial
situations this passenger was pregnant
it's not very common to see pregnant
women work as drug carriers and she said
she did this precisely because she
needed the
money the woman will be transferred to
prison if found guilty she could face 5
to 15
years if it is confirmed that she's
pregnant she may be able to serve her
sentence under house
arrest we intercept narcotics using
officers who specialize in identifying
suspicious
passengers conducting interviews and
making
arrests it is important that our
citizens know the society knows
nationally and internationally that we
make every effort to stop drugs from
leaving our
country
[Music]
fore